y llegó el momento de hablar de revista
de prensa en directo américa de france
24 ya está lista en el estudio rosa
pérez más de euros a bienvenida feliz
lunes empezamos entonces esta sección
con un repaso de la prensa francesa tras
el domingo marcado por la agenda
electoral recordemos que entonces en el
mes de abril son éstas a prime éstas la
primera vuelta de las elecciones y
también la segunda vamos a ver entonces
qué pasa pero ayer tuvo lugar a rosa por
un lado el mitin de valérie pécresse la
candidata del partido derecha
conservadora los republicanos y el otro
lado el líder de la francia insumisa
hablamos de jean-luc mélenchon que
destaque entonces hablamos de los medios
diversión en media parte y le moto
buenos días exactamente raúl nos hemos
fijado en algunos titulares que repasan
estos dos mitin por un lado media parte
señala lo que ya hemos venido comentando
y es la radicalización de la derecha
francesa y titula pécresse en el cenit
del zenit es la sala de conciertos donde
tuvo lugar el acto un mitin fallido y
préstamos de la extrema derecha y en su
crónica el periodista y les andan y lo
describe como un discurso laborioso en
la foto pero que fue sobre todo la
ocasión de hacer guiños a las ideas de
extrema derecha y que recurrió
constantemente al concepto racista tan
es vivido por temor de el gran reemplazo
y precisamente esto es lo que titula
liberación el gran reemplazo el gran
error de valérie pécresse
precisamente el periodista jonathan
busset pettersen señala que el uso de
este tótem de la extrema derecha en su
meeting de parís muestra hasta qué punto
la candidata de los republicanos está en
un curso en un punto muerto entre el
liberalismo pro business de macrón y el
liberalismo xenófobo de eriksen y para
terminar en el mont dice con un artículo
de julie carrier en montería donde tuvo
lugar el meeting de jean luc mélenchon
de la izquierda de la francia insumisa
jean-luc mélenchon e intenta imponerse
como único candidato eficaz de la
izquierda esta izquierda tan dividida
que hemos comentado aquí tantas veces
rosa y entonces seguimos sobre un tema
relacionado con lo que venimos hablando
hablamos de un reportaje en james que
titula la silenciosa subida de los
musulmanes de francia rosa porque este
es un reportaje de honor y mitsubishi y
ayuda a la mit que señala un fenómeno
que dice que pasa por alto tanto a nivel
mediático como a nivel político dice
todo el debate en la campaña de la
elección presidencial francesa gira
alrededor de la inmigración sin embargo
es la creciente emigración de musulmanes
franceses lo que evidencia una crisis
más profunda para el país y es que
señala como ante el auge de la
islamofobia en francia muchos musulmanes
deciden instalarse en otros lugares
rápidamente para señalar una párrafo de
este artículo dice los lugares en los
que se han establecido como reino unido
o eeuu no son países libres de
discriminación contra los musulmanes ni
contra otras minorías sin embargo
aseguran los entrevistados que ahí
tienen más oportunidades y aceptación
fue fuera de francia donde por primera
vez el simple hecho de ser franceses no
les fue cuestionado aseguran algunos y
este es un tema como se nada que cada
vez se estudia y se analiza en distintas
universidades europeas
dejamos europa nos venimos a nuestro
continente de nuestra región y nos
fijamos en el medio peruano ojo público
que publica la fotografía rosa del mal
estado las tuberías de la petrolera
operada por repsol que causó el derrame
de crudo en las costas peruanas exacto
este reportaje de mitra tag accede a
unas fotografías que forman parte de la
investigación de la fiscalía sobre este
derrame de crudo y estas fotografías son
mostradas a distintos expertos que todos
detectan lo mismo y es una mal uso de
las instalaciones más bien una falta de
mantenimiento que había provocado y
habría propiciado este desastre y esto
tal y como señala este artículo
contradice la versión de repsol que
desde el principio intenta eludir sus
responsabilidades
y cerramos con un tema que hemos
comentado anteriormente en esta sección
de revista de prensa rosa hablamos de la
prohibición de la novela gráfica mouse
que aborda el tema del holocausto en un
distrito escolar esto a esta prohibición
fue en el distrito escolar de tennessee
en eeuu el país entrevista entonces al
autor de este libro art pietschmann que
sostiene que prohibir los libros sol
enciende el interés por leer los
exactamente el autor de esta
conocidísima y reconocida novela gráfica
se describe como un defensor total de la
libertad de expresión y dice que por
ello le ha causado mucha curiosidad pues
acceder a las actas de éste de esta
junta de este distrito de escolar donde
pues se decidió por unanimidad retirar
del currículo escolar esta novela
gráfica que como decíamos abordar el
holocausto de hecho el autor se basó en
la experiencia de su padre un judío
polaco en el campo de concentración de
auschwitz y dice que tal recordemos este
libro fue prohibido por ocho palabrotas
y un desnudo dentro de la novela gráfica
que es uno de los comentarios que
figuran en las actas tal y como señala
el autor es porque nuestros muchachos
deberían ver esto y él dice yo lo único
que hice fue describir el holocausto sin
sensacionalismos no hay que conocer la
realidad tal y como fue y sólo para
terminar en referencia al titular se han
disparado las ventas de esta novela
gráfica desde que salió la noticia su
prohibición en este distrito escolar y
dice el autor spiegelman que va a usar
estos beneficios para financiar por
ejemplo campañas de registro de votantes
entre otras causas democráticas todo lo
prohibido por supuesto llama la atención
rosa muchísimas gracias por esta sección
de revista de prensa nos vemos la mañana
con más nosotros vamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado el día